[Music]
as our valley gets ready to celebrate
the fourth of july
we caught up with some safety experts
about the lack of a supply of fireworks
at local stands
according to tnt fireworks the shortage
is affecting the entire industry
the company says this is due to the
coronavirus shutdowns in china as well
as shipping challenges
so they recommend buying fireworks early
selection will be a bit limited this
year
if you're lighting off your own
fireworks make sure you're safe and sane
when you choose to be a consumer
fireworks you got to do that responsibly
so we want to make sure everybody
remembers to follow the safety tips that
are out there be responsible
pick the right kind of site for your a
fireworks show
flat surface concrete or paved watch out
for any type of flammables
as he mentioned make sure you have a
water source nearby as well remember to
dispose of the fireworks responsibly
tnt fireworks is the nation's largest
distributor with hundreds of locations
throughout our state